now why Harlequin well this is my first
cosplay I didn't want to do anything too
over-the-top so so I sort of took her
outfit I thought I really want to wear
that because of quite a few people do it
so I designed myself this and put this
together and oddly I just like her
character she's funny and I'm really
into Batman so that helps you said that
you kind of took it and made it your own
so which particular elements if you take
fun with it in comics is that the it was
from the original comics but it's just
pretty much just taking the colors
rearranged and doing what I want with it
take these put together because there's
loads of bits to it isn't it well it's
kind of still in progress but the Hat
took the longest and that was a whole
week just because I hadn't really done
any sewing and stuff before and I needed
to make pattern and everything else but
um I bought them bought the cat suit so
it in total probably about three weeks
sort of thing yeah you've got a cause of
the face paint on the Mars the contacts
well I have the contact
oh I'm fine with contacts although I'm
actually short-sighted so I can't really
see all that much but um yeah no it's
alright and a face paint takes forever
to put on I do want to do more costumes
because a lot I come mainly for other
cosplayers and seeing friends and things
so they all they all do a different
costume each day and I'm sort of staying
the same thing I feel like I really want
to get and do something else so you
would you like to do next ideally I
think next I'm making you another
costume for MCM in May and I'm in a rule
63 group rule 63 is like taking a
character of the opposite sex and making
it your sex so I'm gonna do the Joker
and and then I'll fair hopefully which
blade they tell me live about the Hat
because there's like it what's keeping
it hmm while keeping my head down but um
it's like I've got really long hair
comes down to about here so I have to
really pin that up and I've got a
basically tight got my head
and to keep that in place and then the
hat is attached to a baseball cap
without the front so and I just have to
really fast in it and it does fall so
have to keep pulling it down but it's
staying in place pretty well today
brilliant really kenning lots going on
into there that doesn't look like it is
that perfect on the outside exit and
what about this as well I didn't I
didn't make this edge for this but I
intend to the handles not very nice so
I'm gonna cut that off and make my own
handle and you've been wreaking havoc
with it as well a little bit a little
bit mostly the gun note because there's
not much room really so yeah there's not
much room we'll enjoy the rest of your
weekend wreaking havoc here at the
London Film and comment card
you